i know you've already spoken about it
but the incident that happened at the
airport that went viral which is just by
the way some real [ __ ] boy [ __ ] what
happened not on your behalf obviously
having like some [ __ ] like that happen
does it just make you like like a little
bit paranoid moving around because i
feel like when you're popular not just
you just anybody you're like
anybody can try to go viral off of just
putting you in a [ __ ] stupid
situation
and it's got to be like
i mean i'd be [ __ ] paranoid after
some [ __ ] like that happened no i mean
it's a society we living in bro just
gotta embrace it everybody got a phone
everybody want some type of clout or
whatever
um
stuff like that happen so you can move
accordingly and prove what was wrong why
did he get that close it's just
something simple like making sure
security with your 2407. not cause you
scared of somebody coming because you're
smart you got a family yeah because like
you know because because what if it what
if it was somebody who was actually what
if somebody what if he had a gun yeah no
we in the air we we was reaction in the
rental car center so you it was you
could have had a gun you know what if
that was the case what if it was
somebody else it was really a threat you
know
so guys just do that to let you know for
this show year you can have one of the
best years of your life you need to have
make sure that you are secure everywhere
you go so that was just he he gave me a
lot of little test runs and [ __ ] this
whole month to let me know that this
year is going to be amazing because it's
this whole this whole month been hell
for me honestly but he's doing it to to
let me peep all the flaws and in the
circle and everything that's going on so
i can improve it so when it comes
further down the line when i'm in
september and something like this was to
happen or you know whatever we'll be
ready to handle it i'm sorry